(upbeat music)
- Vegas is like constantly
living under stage lights.
Vegas is like the old-time, big movie set,
and Vegas' relationship
with drag is fantastic.
Whether it's a showgirl on the strip
or a showgirl who happens
to be a boy in a night club,
we're all entertaining people
and this town loves entertainment.
- I'm Alex Serpa.
- I'm Daniel HoneyCutt.
We're the Queens of Las Vegas,
and we host What a Drag.
- And we host “What a Drag.
- [Both] The longest-running
drag show in Las Vegas.
- What a Drag started in 1996.
It's everything in Vegas,
everything in Hollywood,
everything on Broadway,
all converted to drag.
Our show is the three C's:
costume, character, and comedy.
- The fact that we're a couple,
I think, is the reason why
Queens of Las Vegas
has managed to persist,
'cause we're a unified
front running the show.
When I was a kid, I would
play in my mom's pumps.
As I got older and I wanted to do drag,
my mother bought me my very first dress.
She saw that drag could be
a creative outlet for me
that would help me develop as a person.
I met Alex at 20, and I,
all those years I had been studying drag,
and Alex told me,
“I see something in you,” you know?
He came up with the idea of
doing a duet and he said,
“We’ll do it together, that
way if you get scared,
“I’m standing next to you.”
- When I told him I can
see something in you,
what I was really thinkin',
I found somebody to do all those duets
that I've always wanted to do.
- When I start doing my makeup,
I have to start with
blocking out my eyebrows,
not that I have much left.
- [Alex] Smooth it out.
- [Daniel] Yeah, and from there
it's about creating contour.
- [Alex] A contour is a permanent shadow.
- [Daniel] And from there
you move on to eyes.
- [Alex] Eyebrows are really important.
- [Daniel] Fake eyelashes.
- [Alex] Fake eyelashes.
- [Daniel] They're always
better the second time.
- [Alex] Lip shaping.
- Oh, yes.
The shape of a lip, it's very important.
- [Alex] The shape of a lip.
Padding.
The hip pads are shaped
like Africa and South
America respectively.
They're not just hip pads,
they're also butt pads.
- What I look for in a wig is character.
And I'm partial to being blonde.
(upbeat music)
- Whatever number you're performing,
you gotta have a gimmick.
The gimmick's gotta last
you all four minutes.
- [Daniel] Chyna Nicole is a showgirl.
- [Alex] Anye Gotti, she's unstoppable.
- Danielle Steelcox,
she's the future of drag.
And Alex and I being a
couple and both doing drag
and hosting the show, we are
family and then we're also
a drag family, so I've always
had a sisterhood around me.
When you come to Vegas,
whether you're a local
or you're a tourist, you
get to be your true self.
- [Alex] There's never a boring moment.
- [Daniel] What a Drag is like Las Vegas
because we don't have limits,
just like Las Vegas.